oh hell yeah I love this show Sam Dean
Sam
the scene opens up in Stillwater
Minnesota where an exciting Hot Dog
Eating competition is taking place
several people participate and after
some grueling rounds the referee
declares the results unfortunately
tempers quickly rise and a heated
argument breaks down between two
participants the runner-up accuses the
winner of cheating asserting that he
witnessed him sneaking a hot dog into
his pocket that's not a hot dog I'm just
pleased his punched to be here but all
his protests are disregarded and the
winner an obese guy named Wayne is
presented with a generous check of one
thousand dollars as his prize shortly
after as Wayne gets into his car ready
to depart he hears a strange noise that
grabs his attention curious he rolls
down his window to investigate but sees
no one in sight just then he finds an
unexpected presence in the back seat of
his car Wayne tries to call for help but
the mysterious individual swiftly
attacks him and sucks all the fat from
his body this leads to his untimely and
painful death
Supernatural on the other hand we are
introduced to two FBI agents named Dean
and Sam who appear to be unhealthily
attractive siblings as they Converse
they are informed by the mysterious
death of Wayne they learned that the
obese man weighed a substantial 316
pounds but now he is somehow dropped to
90. this intrigues the agents so they
decide to proceed with the investigation
in the next scene they arrive at the
police station in Stillwater ripping
that sweet Impala and meet with Sheriff
Donna who provides them with crucial
information about the victim's condition
Donna reveals that the victim suffered
from severe internal injuries including
a ruptured spleen pierced liver and
collapsed lungs among other ailments
hearing this Dean and Sam inquire about
possible enemies the victim may have had
in response Donna discloses details
about Jim the runner-up in the earlier
Hot Dog Eating competition who had
engaged in a heated dispute with Wayne
the victim also had an adversarial
relationship with donuts with this
information the two agents rushed to
Jim's residence and find him training
for the next eating competition he is
desperate to claim the first prize this
time around during their investigation
the agents stumble upon strange objects
that give off witchcraft Vibes when
asked about them Jim explains that his
wife Mala is a gypsy who has crafted
good luck charms for him after a while
as Sam is snooping around the bedroom he
finds a gypsy bag that belongs to Mala
thinking that it could be used as
evidence he grabs it without permission
and the two agents depart quickly as
soon as they arrive at their motel room
Dean and Sam closely examined the
contents of the bag only to realize that
it is in fact a hex bag not long after
their investigation is interrupted when
there is a sudden knock at their door to
their surprise it's Mala who has come to
retrieve her bag how she knew the
location of the motel is a mystery we
may never solve as the detectives ask
Mala questions she reveals something
shocking it turns out she had an affair
with Wayne and they both met on regular
occasion Mala also confesses that she
used the hex bag to bless his success
this is why Wayne won almost every
competition he participated in mala's
Ultimate plan was to divorce Jim and run
off with the prize money to Orlando
hearing all of this the agent are left
stunned Sam Dean what do you think Sam
Dean the scene then cuts to a local
Health Club where a woman is working out
during the late hours as she completes
her exercise routine she climbs onto the
scale to measure herself the woman hopes
that she has lost some weight but to her
dismay she still weighs the exact same
meanwhile the mysterious figure from
earlier is seen lurking in the shadows
observing her every move then at an
opportune moment it strikes her from
behind renders her unconscious and sucks
all the body from her fat I think we got
that backwards the next day Dean and Sam
arrive at the scene of the murder they
uncover a disturbing similarity between
this victim and the previous one they
both lost an excessive amount of weight
before their untimely demise furthermore
the agents detect a strange mark on the
deceased woman's stomach which they
assume to be a suction Mark after this
Dean heads to question the person in
charge of the gym while Sam heads to the
morgue to examine the body of the first
victim according to the gym leader she
handed over the key to the victim and
left early as she had a date to get to
in the middle of their conversation the
manager reaches for a tissue when Dean
notices a similar suction mark on her
back he immediately questions her about
it but the woman becomes startled and
doesn't say anything later that day the
two agents meet at their Motel where
they exchange and combine their findings
Dean shares his Discovery regarding the
gym manager's suction Mark revealing
that she had recently undergone
significant weight loss at Canyon Valley
Spa in order to dig up further
information the two head to that Spa
which seems to be offering a mysterious
way to lose weight without dieting or
exercising upon reaching there Dean and
Sam poses personal trainers who are in
search of jobs they claim that they have
years of experience in this field to
their luck the owners of the spa Larry
and his wife Maritza buy their story and
welcome them they then start explaining
their background in the unique services
that they offer after a brief
conversation Larry and Maritza hire Sam
as a trainer while Dean is assigned to
work in the food service department
later on we see Sheriff Donna at the
same Spa hoping to find some relaxing
respite from her duties she schedules a
session with Maritza and the latter
introduces the concept of cupping a
procedure for losing weight well it
sounds like a sex thing Maritza asserts
that even celebrities resort to this
technique as it eliminates toxins from
the body the unsuspecting Sheriff agrees
to the procedure without thinking much
of it but after she dozes off Maritza
suddenly sticks out her monstrous
probiscus and starts sucking the fat
from the sheriff's body in another part
of the spa Dean is seen working in the
kitchen preparing meals for the visitors
meanwhile Sam finds himself in a
somewhat uncomfortable situation as he
awkwardly takes the role of a yoga
instructor guiding a class through
various poses this one's called the
downward Dean but this turns out to be
the perfect opportunity to gather more
information Sam discreetly observes the
clients and shockingly finds that they
all have suction marks on their backs
back in the kitchen Dean is overwhelmed
by hunger so he stashes about of pudding
in his pocket he then sneaks away to the
basement and starts enjoying it as Dean
finishes eating an unexpected sensation
washes over him as he begins to feel
light-headed and dizzy implying that the
pudding contains a heavy dose of
sedative but before he passes out
completely Dean manages to summon his
brother urgently seeking assistance in
the next scene as Sam reaches the
basement he finds Dean lying down next
to a pile of sweet potatoes after
learning about the drugged pudding he
confronts the chef angrily the latter
tries to claim innocence but when Sam
keeps on pushing he reveals that he was
forced to add supplements to the dishes
on the order of Larry and Maritza later
in the evening Sam and Dean are having a
conversation with Donna who eagerly
shares her Joy at having lost 10 pounds
on her very first day at Canyon Valley
Spa she also confides in them about her
past revealing that her husband
abandoned her because she was chunky and
loved food from that day onwards she
wanted to feel pretty and desirable
again Donna worked hard for years but
didn't get any results but now at Canyon
Valley Spa she is finally fulfilling her
wish as their discussion progresses Sam
and Dean shift the focus to the
mysterious connection between the spa
and the murders they've been
investigating they bring up the topic of
the suction marks and to their surprise
Donna reveals the same mark on her own
body however she insists that it's a
result of maritza's cupping procedure
it's just a sex thing the agents that
inquire about the pudding and Donna
confirms that she ate some too prior to
her session hearing all of this the
brothers connect some dots and finally
come to the conclusion that Maritza is
the prime suspect for the murders on the
other hand the evil couple also finds
out that Sam and Dean are undercover
agents this causes them to panic and
they decide to get rid of the evidence
as soon as possible Maritza begins
dumping the containers filled with the
extracted fat into the garbage but at
the same time Sam and Dean walk in and
catch her red-handed now that she's
apprehended Maritza decides to come
clean about everything she reveals that
she is a pistachio a pish Taco a fat
sucking creature originating from from
Peru however she denies being a murderer
asserting that she is merely a parasite
with no intention of causing harm
Maritza claims that her feeding on
people's excess fat created a mutually
beneficial situation by helping people
lose weight when questioned about the
murders she says that the guilty party
must be Alonso her younger brother who
works in the kitchen meanwhile Larry
confronts Alonso about his wrong deeds
and demands that he leave the spa
immediately however this only makes the
murderer angry and he ends up killing
Larry as well news of Larry's demise
reaches the agents shortly after and as
they inform Maritza about the same she
has left devastated and heartbroken when
questioned further she unveils the
backstory of her brother's Presence at
the spa she explains that she brought
Alonso from Peru with hopes of offering
him a better life but one day he nearly
killed a client by extracting an
excessive amount of fat realizing that
he is a ticking Time Bomb Maritza
demoted him to the kitchen only allowing
him to feed on fats stored in jars
unfortunately the more she limited his
ax success the more insatiable his
hunger became which is what led to the
series of murders the Revelation leaves
the agents with no choice but to hunt
Alonso down so they inquire about his
whereabouts Maritza who is also looking
to avenge her husband's death directs
them to the basement without any
hesitation following this Sam and Dean
head to the dark basement in search of
Alonso as they slowly move forward they
come across bloodstains along their path
eventually they enter a room where they
discover the lifeless body of the chef
with his throat brutally ripped out the
agents are disgusted by the scene but
they decide to continue exploring for
now after a while Alonso suddenly
attacks Sam from behind and prepares to
suck all the fat out of him but before
he can do so as usual Dean arrives in
the nick of time and slashes alonso's
throat finally ending his life following
this the police arrive at the spa to
handle the bodies while Sam approaches
Maritza and offers her Comfort he
informs her that he lied to the police
about her illegal business to save her
from jail time Maritza expresses her
gratitude for all that he has done but
Sam tells her that it's best if she were
to return to Peru there she can be with
her people and live happily ever after
Maritza is a bit conflicted about the
idea as she came to the states to live
her dream however after a long thought
she agrees the episode ends as both
brothers return to their bunkers and
chat about their love lives and stuff
they just do brother things because
that's what brothers do subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching